and the first scene we did is the scene
on the train is pretty intimate scene
with me and Killian Murphy and Chris was
like he made me do 14 takes of my
closeup and this is a guy that does like
three takes typically and this is your
first scene you're shooting day now were
you thinking about oh my God everybody's
looking at me Killian Murphy thinks I'm
terrible I'm bombing I'm gonna get fired
all these things you're thinking of
you're obsessing oh consciously in the
moment and it doesn't help that Chris is
like I don't know what you're doing and
I'm I'm thinking to myself well cuz I'm
on that tiny monitor you know but he
wanted something different than what I
was planning and you know I had to
adjust on the fly but